well I never thought I would see the day
where big brown got well almost got in a
fight so we were piled in my Porsche at
the time which I had out in that red
Porsche so I get off on the exit me
writes in their joke and whenever Bowl
[ __ ] and I see this guy and he's yelling
like furious I'm like look at that guy
be with the yellow net and then Brian's
uh I think's talking to you so roll down
the window like what's up man anything
you cut me off you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you Baba I'm like what the hell so I'm
like whatever I wrote the window homeboy
gets out of car yeah
first he slaps the piss out of my car
claps Mitch slaps his car [ __ ] slap
[ __ ] slaps his red Porsche hard I'm not
like oh hell no and then as he makes it
his way over to my car door he kicks the
car and then I get out of the car calm
calm calm did you escalate the situation
so he's yelling at me and he's getting
closer he's getting louder no what are
you gonna do then we get old nose to
nose and I think that he kind of went
this guy's big but he's got to be a
[ __ ] didn't watch UFC and he gets in
your face not nose nose cuz he was
shorter but thick so he was more nose to
chin on you but you know like it sucked
on his nose
you could have sucked this nose you
could have sucked his nose go snorkel
you could definitely smell his breath
I'm sure to remember what you said is
the funniest thing in the world use what
sir you're pushing up against my bubble
oh good
and I'm about to bust know in the best
part is Brian's in the car this whole
time not doing et just giggling behind
my hands he rolls down the window sticks
his head out and goes bust you turn
around he got his car and I read like
three workers I think they're his kids
and they were older like 18 19 20 at
least I just point at the three kids
went and stay in school and I got back
in the car and we took off we just took
off yeah I'm embarrassed shout out to
that guy